who's the better employee VIN or Mack
nah it's Mack so yeah I'd say you
probably got that covered
hey what's up guys I'm QB HD here did
you want to gonna come back alright
what's up guys I'm Kip EHD here welcome
back to a QA I don't have any more you
want to treat probably I don't have
anymore
welcome to Q&A number 25 we're doing one
every bye we're doing one every month
this is February so it's the second one
of 2018 and I asked you guys questions
on Twitter and a little bit from a
reddit thread as well from the subreddit
and you guys had great questions so here
are the answers what you want to do on
stage if you won this shorty okay this
is actually a good opportunity to plug
this for the last time so today is the
final day that you can vote for mkbhd
for a shorty award for creator of the
decade it's a ridiculous honor and
there's an awesome crew of other
youtubers also nominated I'll leave the
link below if you want to vote it ends
like tonight at midnight so I'll stop
talking about it after this point but
yeah that's linked below also I have no
idea what I would do on stage if I won
because I fully do not expect to
actually win that how many views did you
get on your first ever a YouTube video
from the time it was uploaded till the
time you uploaded your second video
that's an interesting question I'd say
probably three or four views of course
that was also at a time where you're not
making the video for getting views it's
just making the videos cuz they're fun
so I probably uploaded my second video
like a day after the first video I've
also pointed to in the past the fact
that I uploaded my first 100 videos for
a total of 74 or 76 subscribers
something like that and made a thank you
video for video number 100 so we're in a
totally different place now but that was
a definitely a good time you were on a
plane and about to take your seat which
gadgets do you have on you interesting
so I guess personally when I'm traveling
just any time I always have my backpack
and in my backpack is always my chargers
for my phones USBC chargers or lightning
chargers and
Bo's QC 35 headphones I literally will
go back to my house to get them if I
forget them I can't fly without them but
then the other interesting thing is if
you're traveling with camera gear you
can't put like a large amount of
batteries under the plane so anytime I
travel with camera gear I also don't
want to check a bag with the red in it
so it's all with me also I have a think
tank bag that's the exact dimensions of
the overhead compartment and it fits a
couple lenses all my batteries to camera
that's always with me if I'm traveling
with cameras and I'm a laptop usually if
it's a long flight I can actually try to
connect to the internet and do a little
bit of work but Nintendo switch also fun
fact is a great size for airplanes it's
not too big that you're like struggling
with the seat in front of you great for
gaming a new recommendation there what
is your monthly data usage like actually
I can check but it's usually pretty high
each other pretty often when I'm
traveling but the last I'm my my usage
allows for five gigs and then I pay for
more unrestricted data after five gigs
which isn't that much but last last
period I used 39 gigs so clearly I pay a
lot more than I have to who do you think
is actually in e lons roadster the one
that's in space I actually asked him and
he said Elvis so there's that how do you
feel about the whole YouTube thing the
4000 watch hours and 1000 subscribers
would demotivate small youtubers
community so I've thought about this for
a bit because I've been a youtuber for a
long time but when I was first starting
out and when I had numbers that were
below that threshold you're not thinking
about how much money you're making
you're more concerned with legitimacy
and growing your audience and actually
making stuff you enjoy so for youtubers
who have been making content under that
amount of money the amount you're
missing out on might be like $3 you're
not gonna be massively concerned about
not getting ad revenue because you
haven't reached that yet so the limit
makes sense for YouTube they want to
limit how many people can just sign up
and make spam channels and re-upload
everyone's footage and make money off of
that until it gets shut down this rule
minimizes that but I don't think it
should be discouraging for small
creators who are going to be building
their audiences anyway and working on
their craft anyway because once they
pass that threshold the amount of money
they've missed out on is almost nothing
and they're actually gonna be still
working on growing their audience does
the sound quality of the home pod fill
the gap Siri leaves as far as assistance
guess so I would say watch that video
watch the home pod video I talked and I
think I pretty much ended the video with
the answer to your question which is
basically guess that's but unless you're
an audiophile in which case home pod
would probably not be your first ever
nice speaker purchase so you got to be
in a really small demographic to want a
home pod who you got in the NBA Finals I
have my Rockets upsetting the Warriors I
mean is it an upset if they're the one
seed Rockets over the Warriors in the
West
Cleveland probably over Boston yeah
probably Boston but I kind of see hugely
going all the way at least because I'm
super biased well Nokia be able to
acquire the same status that they were
previously known for this is a fun one
because my answer is no I don't see them
being one of the most sold phones of all
time ever again that's actually
something a lot of people don't knows if
you look at the like a Wikipedia chart
of the highest selling individual
smartphones of all time Nokia has a lot
of spots on that list but it's with
those classics like the 33 10 and like
the 33 50 actually have one from when I
did that April Fool's video a couple of
them actually but since this time since
this dominant time of Nokia selling
millions and millions of phones they
haven't really had any major hits like
this they've had some windows phones
that have been pretty solid it seems
like they've decided that this is the
best they're gonna do because this is
the latest phone that they've released
which is the 3310 again it still plays
snake it's still what they think is
their best choice so as much as I really
ruin blackberry about how behind all the
times they are Nokia is also feeling
that nostalgia pretty hard so I don't I
don't foresee them reaching these
heights again this was kind of a go all
right so we can do a couple from the
subreddit here does the merch line have
plans to release hoodies in the future
love the videos keep up the amazing work
thank you sir so for the merch line
that's something we've heard a lot about
is you know suggestions for what
which I asked for probably the number
one suggestion was people in colder
climates who don't wear t-shirts is
often some sort of a long sleeve or
jacket or hoodie option and we hear that
loud and clear and just generally we've
heard a lot of great feedback about the
things that you've been able to order
plenty of people have ordered them I'm
pretty excited for you guys to rock them
the link of course is always below or in
bio as a matter of fact I think I've
enjoyed this this little launch so much
that I feel like giving away a free
shirt I'll give away one of the pieces
emerged so basically how this works is
it's a promo code you'll have to type it
in so make sure you I guess you're on
the site right now and you probably have
what you want in your cart so do that if
you're ready I'll just go ahead and read
this out all right so it's p b z s w p4
c c8 and then you hit apply and it's
probably gone assuming you weren't first
here's a couple of this if you're a if
you're faster all right how is how has
having additional team members increase
video production efficiency or quality
of your videos it's a great question
that I've also seen a lot I think the
short answer to that is just more better
typically the relationship for a creator
between more videos and better videos is
inverse if you want to make a lot more
videos typically they don't get a lot
better if you want to make much better
videos typically they don't happen very
often but having more hands and
like-minded extremely talented people on
board makes it so that I can kind of
increase both a little bit at the same
time ideally I mean I'm still learning
we're all still sort of building this
together but that's the goal more better
now as someone says how do you spell
your middle name with a K anyway I'm
gonna end it there that's been a wrap
thanks for watching these Q&A videos all
the relevant links are below everything
you saw in this video but yeah thanks
for thanks for being a part of this this
has been a pretty solid start to 2018
and I feel like a lot of good stuff is
coming until the next one thanks for
watching talk to you later
pace